thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show in the lobby of
Ramsey solutions headquarters Bruce and
Patti are with us hey guys how are you
doing well thank you thank you thank you
good to have you so where are you guys
from Ventura California
ah Los Angeles okay cool well good to
have you thanks for hanging out yeah
preciate you being here and so you're
here all the way on those how the United
States do your debt-free screen
yes service I love it how much have you
paid off two hundred and seventy six
thousand dollars I love it very cool and
how long did that take three and a half
years
alright good very good and what was your
range of income during that three and a
half years uh $200,000 okay cool what do
you guys do for a living I'm once
retired and working for a large
aerospace company right now okay and I
work for the court system they're very
cool good well good to have good to have
you
so 276,000 what was that what you pay
off mortgage you pay off your house
that's it you don't have any dad no dad
I'm looking at weird people I love it
very cool congratulations you guys thank
you very cool very cool
what's this house worth five hundred and
seventeen thousand dollars oh and it's
yours oh yeah nobody leaning over that
thing man I love it way to go you guys
so what this made you decide to pay off
your house and start working towards
this three and a half years ago well we
we were pretty much debt-free other than
the house you heard of that and my
sister gave us your book and so she said
oh this might help you might not help
you whatever but we read it and or I
read it and I forget about it and we
just decided before we retire mm-hmm we
really want to get serious and get this
house paid for mm-hmm and so that's ever
since then we've just been going at it
so you just said okay extra payments
you're like
this comes they on a budget attack this
debt exactly I love it very cool so the
total money makeover book is at the boat
alright good very good cool so how old
are you two 60 and 62 okay so when do
you plan to retire next year
oh wow 2018 yeah there we go
again yeah that's right that's right you
said earlier you're a [ __ ] once yes
very good well and this makes it easy
any pain yeah exactly you got a paid-for
house in freakin California and there's
a big deal it's a big deal so way to go
you guys thank you how does it feel to
not have even a house payment oh great
such a relief yes just so nice knowing
going into retirement that we that we
just don't have to worry about that yeah
so we can let up on the beans and rice a
little bit I think you can make it 200
and no payments in the world I think
you're gonna be alright
you probably gonna be able to struggle
through all this I love it maybe maybe
upgrade to a taco yeah we go well done
well done well since you're going to
retire soon we're gonna give you a copy
of Chris Hogan's book retire inspired
because that is the next chapter for
sure can in are all situations signed by
him because I mean this is a story
you're living it's a journey and this is
one chapter close that chapter on it
your baby steps seven people now you
paid off your house and now you're just
saving and investing and being
outrageously generous that's right
that's where you'll be well what is your
advice to someone that's in their 50s
and they never paid off their house I
never thought they could because I mean
you chunked off a lot of debt here in
three and a half years just just go
ahead every little thing you got just
throw at the house and also have
somebody that's pretty dedicated oh we
both were dedicated so you're saying
Patti's a little bit of a nerd yeah
she's the nerd I like it I like it I was
the one that would you know like to go
out for the bacon and eggs for breakfast
which we didn't get to do anymore
now you can have steak with okay yeah
all right good
well well done thanks Patti good job all
right Bruce and Patty Los Angeles
California two hundred and seventy six
thousand dollars paid off
in three and a half years that's their
house and everything baby making 200k
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
well done well done well done man I'm
telling you there's nothing like having
a paid-for house hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common